it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week you pissed off
the taken king by killing his son but
that means more story and more levels so
it's never been a better time to get
back into destiny a revamped quest
format at story context and a natural
progression path to old and new content
Nolan North is now the voice of your
ghost start to finish and new content
focuses on warm meaningful storytelling
but most importantly there's a new level
cap of 40 gamespot producer Eric Tay and
reviewer Michael Hardy have a bet going
to see who can get to 40 first loser has
to buy the winner a steak dinner this is
how heroes are made people start
leveling on the 15th apology all week
also this week turn 10 studios makes us
ooh and ahh at the hyper realistic cars
and raceways in Forza Motorsport 6 the
game will include more than 450 cars
more than twice the number of the cars
available at launch in Forza Motorsport
5 also unlike Forza Motorsport 5 where
you had to acquire tokens through
microtransactions just to get certain
vehicles in four to six all these cars
are available at launch without tokens
thank you we also get wet weather
driving which isn't just for looks rain
can cause tires to skid or even
hydroplane so keep your eyes on the
skies no wait keep them on the road
start shifting gears on the 15th
pro evolution soccer 2016 is making a
huge effort to cut in on FIFA's
territory with refined gameplay improved
graphics and kick-ass music even though
PES 16 is powered by the same Fox engine
as last year you'll probably notice a
pretty big improvement in the visuals it
looks good but khonani emphasize that
this year's releases about the gameplay
with more freedom for creativity when
controlling your team and enhanced
celebrations for that extra power in
your face you get to corner kick on the
15th also this week a few games just too
big to ignore world of warships is an
MMO of oceanic proportions much like
wargaming's world of tanks and World of
Warplanes it will be free to play with
players selecting different vessels to
play particular roles and lead their
fleet to victory that's out on the 17th
bedlam is a strategic roguelike
turn-based RPG you're the mechanic the
last known member of once-thriving guild
of brilliant operators of the rolling
fortresses called dozers you're in
charge of commanding your crew and
battles managing your resources
improving your dozer interacting various
characters and protecting your
passengers while navigating the
post-apocalyptic wasteland make it to
the Aztec city on the 17th
pyros rejoice this week with flame over
burning its way to ps4 it's a top-down
water am up game with roguelike RPG
elements splash and spray your way
through all 16 floors of deadly internal
industries building you get to combat
ferocious fires in a red-hot adventure
that changes every time all while saving
people and keep that you can be here
stop drop and roll on the 15th finally
put on your oversized jersey and head
out onto the ice with NHL 16 in
gamespot's recent preview of the game
Matt Padgett stated that the on-ice
trainer helps in so many aspects of the
game face offs to shooting to being a
better goalie play online with up to 12
skaters including user controlled
goalies doc Emrick will be there calling
the place Eddie and ray will be
analyzing all your moobs for that
real-life game day feel one of the
oldest and most iconic traditions in
hockey is here with accurate
representations of beard patterns that's
right length thickness and growth rates
of individual players the road to the
Stanley Cup just got hairier get that
lush beard on on the 15 for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week
you